great so let's move forward and
understand where we position ourselves
among our competitors but first we need
to analyze our competition now there are
four levels of market competition which
we use to assess our competitors in the
industry and how we are placed in the
industry
so the four levels of competition our
product form products category generic
and budget competition
so let's go through this with a tangible
example let's take flavored water a this
is a lightly flavored water without any
added sugar competition at the product
form level will include products that
have the exact same features and similar
values as our product so a competitor at
the product forum level would be
flavored water B this is another
flavored water without any added sugar
just gives you a little extra kick to
your water now product forum competition
is extremely narrow we only consider
products that are actually the exact
same just different brands so both of
these waters or flavored waters without
any added sugar they just serve
different brands now product category
competition includes products with
similar features but it's a little bit
of a bigger scope than product form so
an example of that would be flavored
sparkling water now this is also
flavored water that doesn't have sugar
but it's a sparkling water so it's a
competitor on the category level now
thinking about our flavored water
example I want you to consider your own
app who are your competitors now think
about products category competition and
product form competition what
competitors do you have in these areas
now fill in each competitors name in the
appropriate field if you don't have your
own app to use feel free to use
abarkment